-Welcome back, everybody!
We're talking to
the one and only Javier Bardem,
who stars
in "Being the Ricardos."
I want to get into that.
I really want to talk about
this, "Being the Ricardos."
But before we talk about that,
I want to say congratulations,
because you also star
in a new movie from Spain,
called "The Good Boss."
-Yes.
-Which received, I want to say,
a record-breaking 20 nominations
for Spain's equivalent
of the Oscars.
And it's Spain's entry for
the International Film Oscar.
Congratulations on that.
That's unbelievable.
-Thank you very much.
I'm -- I'm very happy to --
representing my country
with this amazing --
this amazing movie.
Let's see where it gets.
-Yeah.
But "Being the Ricardos,"
I'm watching this,
because I'm a fan, obviously,
of Lucille Ball, "I Love Lucy."
And I go, "Okay.
I just want to see, you know,
hopefully, Nicole nails --"
I don't know if she's gonna
do an impression or what.
She didn't.
She just is Lucille.
She's amazing.
It's not an impression.
It's just amazing acting.
And then you come in
and knock it out of the park
as Desi Arnaz.
-Thank you.
-I'm -- I've seen every episode.
I know the way he acts,
the way he talks,
the way he sings.
I mean, did you know how to play
congas and guitar and sing?
And...?
-No, of course not.
I didn't know anything.
But I -- I lied.
And I said to the director
I knew how to do everything.
[ Laughter ]
And -- as every actor should do.
We first lie, get the contract,
get -- get us signed.
And once we are signed, then we
cope with the consequences.
[ Laughter ]
That's what happened.
-I mean --
-The good thing is that Aaron,
through zoom, he knew
exactly that I was lying
when he asked me, "Do you sing?"
"Of course."
"Do you play guitar?"
"Oh, my God.
I was born with a guitar."
"Do you play congas?"
"Congas? I have one here.
Do you want to hear it?"
"Do you dance?"
"Dance?
Jesus, stop me.
I can't -- I can't
stop dancing all day long."
[ Laughter ]
"Do you speak
with a Cuban accent?"
"Anytime."
-That is very convincing.
-"You speak
with an English accent?"
"Oh, yeah.
I speak English perfectly."
And then, his glasses were
like -- like, steaming up.
-Oh, really?
Aaron's?
-Like, the steam
was going out and saying,
"Jesus, he's such a liar."
[ Laughter ]
But she was so nice
to really go with the lie...
-Yeah.
-...and give me a chance.
-It turned out so great.
What a good gamble on a lie.
And, man, you were just
so convincing,
and it was just -- it was --
It's beautiful.
It's -- I don't know.
How would you describe
"Being the Ricardos"?
-It's the story about
two great geniuses of comedy,
genius that really created
a different world and shaped
the world of comedy
and TV comedy, TV programs,
comedy programs
as we know today.
And also, the love story
between a woman and a man
and how much they have to cope
with one another
and trust each other
and really try to make it.
-Yeah.
-To make it through.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
You're fantastic in it.
Here's Javier Bardem
as Desi Arnaz
in "Being the Ricardos."
Take a look.
♪♪
-♪ Olé, olé, olé olé ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
That's exactly right!
Yes!
Javier Bardem, everybody!
"Being the Ricardos" is in
theaters and on Prime Video.